ATSUKO OKATSUKA:
Keep your head down,
and blend in
as much as possible.
At least, that's what
my family would tell me.
And then they named me
Atsuko Okatsuka.
And then they went on
to choose English names
for themselves.
Thanks, Mom!
Or Linda.
My grandma raised me,
so I didn't really hang out
with people my age growing up.
People are always like,
"Atsuko, what's wrong with you?"
Someone 50 years older
than me
taught me how to socialize,
okay?
Whenever I would try
to make friends as a kid,
I was always, like,
telling war stories and stuff.
Trying to trade food recipes.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
My husband and I had
an intruder come to our house.
My fearless husband,
he rushes out,
starts to shake his hand
in the air like this.
The guy kinda watches this,
freaks out,
and starts to run away.
It works.
Different fighting style.
Mind tricks.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪